20 20 US presidential elections already
seeing a spike in the number of
Democratic candidates very eager to
challenge Donald Trump now New York City
Mayor Bill DeBlasio has become the 23rd
Democrat to announce his campaign and it
seems the party is focusing on divisions
in u.s. society rather than unity in it
it's kind of movement explains the way
politics is supposed to work candidates
are expected to win the hearts and minds
of voters by promising ways that they
can fix up the country's problems and
pointing a way forward for America
however in 2019 it seems that a lot of
candidates are arguing rather that who
they are in terms of age race and gender
is more important than any policy
proposals I think we need to articulate
the values lay out our philosophical
commitments and then develop policies
off of that Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
both of them elderly white men are the
two top candidates for the Democratic
nomination in the year of 2020 now
regardless of their policies that fact
alone has got top Democrats crying
sexism I think is just gender bias I
think people are genuinely biased
against women I think also biased
against young women there's just bias
and it's real and it exists but you have
to overcome it a female candidate Amy
Klobuchar has been accused of being too
harsh stories of her mistreating her
former staff members and creating a
harsh work environment have found their
way into the press now her supporters
say that is not a legit concern that's
sexism and a coalition of women's groups
has stepped up to say that the media's
coverage of the 2020 race is laced in
sexism and gender bias now it's
important to note that Hillary Clinton
made similar arguments back in 2016 I
haven't been shouting but sometimes when
a woman speaks out some people think
it's shouting Democrats have been
quibbling about the importance of women
and minorities to counter Trump's
so-called white identity Trump has
perfected white identity politics the
Republican Party is increasingly a white
identity politics party in today's
America why come up with complex policy
proposals when you can simply run on the
basis of
you were born asked and why defend
yourself with logical arguments when you
can simply decry your opponent as being
a bigot in today's America it seems that
identity politics is a new reality as
the country shapes up for the next
election although I didn't see politics
come from the left because that's what
they've been hinging their campaigns on
for the past few years they're creating
division all to try and get certain
people on their side that believed the
same way they do last time in 2016 there
was no so-called person of color on the
Democratic side a battle over who's
going to be the actual candidate there's
going to be some identity politics going
on there if Joe Biden is successful
people may say oh well you had a woman
over here a black person over here an
LGBTQ person over here why weren't they
elected and then if a person that is not
a straight white male becomes the
nominee then the problem will be if they
lose it was because they are of
disparate if particular identities
you